[Music]
you
[Music]
are not like the other gods that kill
because i have something worth fighting
for
[Music]
hello everyone i'm jacqueline coley a
correspondent for fandango and ahead of
tickets on sale i'm here to chat with
the cast and filmmakers of thor love and
thunder chris tessa taika thank you for
being here come get those cookies yes
that's right so it's been a few years
since it's been a year since we saw
these guys before but i'm just curious
if you can let us know where does this
fall in the timeline of the events of
in-game taika like where are we picking
up as
just after the death star blew up
right before han solo comes in and yeah
that's it where does you know more about
marvel movies than i do
end game
left with thor giving the kingship to
valkyrie yeah on earth and thor was in a
pretty emotionally complex place at the
time what was his physique like
he was a little out of shape all right
represented his emotional kind of
complexity and uh he went off on a
journey of self-discovery with the
guardians of the galaxy
and that's kind of where we pick up yeah
we pick up
he's in a little bit of an existential
crisis point and he's trying to figure
out who he is
what his purpose is you know is he
really meant to be a superhero or is
there something else basically it's a
midlife crisis yeah you know that point
everyone uh everyone in everyone's
experienced this you wake up you're like
am i doing what i should be doing yeah
and that's where he's at it's a biopic
but i mean i'm just i'm just asking this
for the internet this is not my query
because i felt that he was gorgeous and
a lovable person on both but has he hit
the gym are we going to get to see like
some montage getting into shape
yes he is he's at the gym he's he's been
back to training yeah yeah yeah um
adjusted his um
regiment from
xbox to
x blocks
i like [ __ ] i like seeing that and then
also valkyrie obviously being you know
the head of the asgardians now this is a
very different place from her than the
drunken sort of wisecracking i don't
want to be anywhere so where does she
find herself on this new journey because
she
i wouldn't say that she's entirely
reformed certainly not in wisecracking
but yeah she's she's taken up the kingly
duties and uh
it's new asgard though so it's like
asgard on earth which is a different
asgard than we've
seen yeah before and she's kind of
trying to
navigate that
exhausted she's exploiting her people
a few random
she's sponsorships all the um
responsibilities of of basically running
a town yeah and looking after your
people but and where we find uh her is
is also missing the battlefield you know
because she spent her entire life as a
career soldier and part of the you know
the valkyrie and now she's kind of got
an admin job which she's like yeah a lot
of meetings a lot of bureaucracy which
is not really
her favorite
she likes
battlecracy
i really do like that i love that we're
getting to get to explore this character
now over four movies because this was
the first sort of solo mcu movie that we
kind of got to see under this kind of
phase but i'm just like what does it
feel like chris you're the only one that
gets four you're like you know like
elbowing tom hall and be like i got four
just so you know i didn't realize i had
until a few weeks ago
you have the most of any yeah no one
else has done four um
it's
that
was
us
no it's cool i i have loved playing this
character and every time
um i've done it i've had an opportunity
to do something different particularly
when tucker turned up and we you know
threw it in a different direction
cookies
and look every time there's a new
creative venture and a different space
to explore um it makes for a fun ride
and a fun time and that this film is
just full of
boundless opportunities to recreate
again
or rebuild thor because as you said from
the last film he was in a different
space um so this film was yeah yeah
journey of self-discovery for all of us
yeah for me too yeah
[Laughter]
a little bit on the spot because i don't
know if you guys know this but one of my
very first interviews as rt was actually
for thor ragnarok and in that interview
taika you let it kind of slip for us
that korg was the one that got to decide
whether or not we came back
for a fourth thor so i just want to know
from you because you said in the
interview we have the clip you're like
it really depends on how big of a
trailer he wants to get and you're like
basically saying like cork so how did
you get at greenlit and when did you
just and when did cork say you go ahead
and do it
um well korg is an incredible um
person
incredible to work with and
i just you know as a director i loved
working with them because it was so cute
there's such symbiosis between the two
yeah and i feel more generous with him
to give him more takes because i feel
like he just brings something different
and yeah you give him
more lines more lines yeah he's a little
difficult to work with yeah he's
sometimes a bit frustrated because he
doesn't learn the script that i've
written yeah and
yeah yeah and he does it on the day
yeah and then he sometimes you know i
could see him he goes and he reads and
he goes why didn't i learn this yeah i
wrote this it's a little rocky with him
but uh no that i don't know how
we basically got this green over dinner
and when the fir when the ragnarok came
out yeah we went and watched called into
a few cinemas around town and then we
went out of dinner and um we started
talking through ideas for this new film
and
that's
with kevin and the rest of marvel
and
i think the film the film became so
beloved that that they
very soon after that they said this is
to another one yeah i love that one and
the dynamic of this one it says right
there in the tagline love and thunder
and so you're coming back into this one
i feel like there's going to be a lot of
ships going on there's people that
shipped you in cork there's people that
shipped you in valkyrie obviously
there's the epic love story of you and
jane like
how is thor's romance what is shipping i
was shipping people that support people
that say like you two should be together
yeah it's like it's kind of like
standing as a couple it's a couple
things yeah shipping shipping is like
two people yeah relationshiping so they
ship you to the couple they didn't make
its way down to australia
yeah
yeah like everything else just got the
espresso martini like that come off it
we just got new zealand just got a third
tv channel
we just got tvs
so yeah where are your relationships uh
going to be at this week is still going
to be like in a triangle quadrangle
you know the
there is love in this film
across the board
everyone has a little awakening in in
one way or another some shape or form
yeah and
um a universal love and love
for oneself one love for friends one for
universe
love for and you know
you know that
you can assume some things from the
title but also don't assume
oh
yeah that's tv that's true
i like that all right so we're going to
add another female dynamic into this
that just means that we don't know what
we're talking about
we can't tell you anything because now
the film ends is is different than what
you might think but i would would say
it's the loviest marvel movie in the
history of marvel movies is that can we
say
that do you think so it's a romance a
romantic comedy it's a comedy
like the one thing i had in my mind the
the picture i had my in my mind was like
a milden boon
cover of like a romantic book and i was
like i want it to feel like that like
you know at times some like melodrama
and like over that like but wanting to
feel and run headfirst into the romance
into the uh into the love aspect of it
and not shy away from it and you know
which i can tend to do in my films as a
new zealander who's cynical and um hates
everything
i
you know i was like no i'm going to
commit to this and i would make sure
this does satisfy people and
satisfy audiences um with the romance i
do love that so much i just want to i
know you're just talking about the
romance you all assume i'm talking about
i do love that well then what do you
feel like the valkyrie jane dynamic is
going to be like because i feel like
these two ladies could have
infinite sort of energies with each
other and i'm so excited to see with
them
um
you know i think i i think first and
foremost
valkyrie is someone who's deeply steeped
in her love of sisterhood you know that
sort of and and and missing that and
longing for that and so
having jane in the universe i think is
is is lovely because she kind of has
access to that thing again of having a
sister and then i think also it's you
know it's delicious
that she is another version of thor i
think about a big love that valkyrie has
is is giving
taking the piss out of her dear friend
and so there's like another opportunity
to do that in a way with with seeing his
counterpart and
you know i mean but chris for you you
guys went off and did ragnarok away from
natalie portman's character
what was it like for her to come on this
set and then just having the jane come
into this new i would say
taika tyka energy of the thor unity
i love it
there's cookies
and that was awesome because the
characters are both in very different
places to when we saw them last
it was also very open-ended as far as
what actually happened did they break up
who left who so on so and i think we all
at one point had to go back and
look at the second film and go how did
they split up so we had the creative
license to do whatever we wanted in that
sense and then a lot of fun
filling in the blanks and and um
and and you know
and creating even more questions and
uncertainty
yeah that happened well i mean did you
did you sit i mean like natalie did you
guys have like dinner together how did
you pitch her to come back into this
because she was you know she's on doing
other things and you got into her house
and she gave me a glass of water
that was a whole thing
that's all cute
uh
she
you know i think that like what we did
with ragnarok was
it
became appealing it made these movies
appealing to um to other actors as well
like you know christian really he saw
that he was like i want to do something
fun and you know came here wanted to be
part of this
this thing and natalie too and you know
i think that um
she was just wanting to make sure that
i didn't know how to say this but like
you know the character in the in her
character in those first few films it's
probably not the most exciting version
of uh you know the female character that
we want from these films and
you know and
i had to just talk to her about the fact
that i wanted to change that character
just like we'd changed um
thor's character for ragnarok and to
give her a bit more um license to be
adventurous and fun and fun because
natalie's a really funny person
and sometimes it's you know
sometimes those sorts of things cannot
be um
i know they're not the main focus when
they come up with characters and you
know in films yeah i will say this
you've done an excellent job i think the
thor franchise has had a plethora of
incredible villains or s
instances where it's like you know jeff
or loki depending on the movie you asked
for and obviously what kate did with
hell is just incredible but christian
like
knowing all these villains that you've
had what is uh what does christian bring
to the villain into into the thor
universe
uh exactly what you'd want hope and
expect uh
nuance complexity
depth um
a sort of quirkiness to it which which i
didn't see on the page
um and
with any sort of classic villain the
fact that you
you find yourself empathizing or or
asking questions that they're asking or
the ideas that they're posing it's not
just stock standards sort of evil yeah
you like root for them sometimes yeah
it's just great if you're playing the
hero yeah everyone's rooting for the
villain so
i'd say he's the most
sympathetic villain yep they've had
um
he's also tested the highest out of any
villain that marvel's had yeah
he's yeah what was it like working with
him yeah well it's also this thing like
that stan lee talked about right which
is that your
your trauma is the thing both that makes
you a superhero and a villain right it's
just in in the case of a villain it's
it's unchecked that your source of pain
is is what manifests into
um
your villainry and i think he captures
that so
well and he just also was so surprising
you know like he just would make choices
that you'd be like oh
uh it just was so fun to watch and such
dexterity and also what he did with his
body and he's really in it and the way
that you would assume christian is but
he also has a sense of humor about it i
don't know it's he's yeah he's a he's a
great actor
and the only other thing he's done is um
this film called empire of the sun and
that was his last job yeah
he was oh he was a letter too yeah he
hasn't worked in an incredible journey
for him yeah yeah it's just to kind of
help you know just kickstart
re-kickstart his career he's very choosy
with his projects it's taking him a long
time he's awesome
yeah i'm so glad he's a part of this
because i can't wait to see what he does
is the christian bale as he said the
actor's name yeah yeah he's going to be
we're going to get there
let's talk about influences too because
there's a bunch of comic nerds that i
know are coming into this knowing the
whole jane thor storyline so i'm going
to ask you about which specific comics
you wanted to pull from but also since
you said romantic comedies i got to know
which romantic comedies would you say
is
loosely inspired about the lord because
i so want to know this here's a great
one how did losing god in 10 days is
great it was a great one things i hate
about you is also a good film oh yeah
yeah clueless is my favorite i'd say i
mean you know it's it's
yeah are these influencing it as well
oh no i don't think there's movies i
like
i'm not sure i'm not sure what
influences i was looking at
i was thinking about like things that
were like
officer and a gentleman
wow like particularly the end scene
where he comes in and sweeps her off her
feet you remember that
it's a wonderful movie um
what else i mean just i i'm
i guess the influences for me were like
really big over-the-top romances like
what i can think of is like
anything with a bob sega song in it
okay i can i can dig that um the other
thing i definitely want to say is that
thor is now known for just epic cameos
like after you did matt and your brother
it's like i think like everyone's
expecting it now can we be in store for
some more i would say epic cameos on
this one
yes
yes nothing on that
otherwise it won't be a cameo
you know what to do you can't talk about
it it'll be a told you yeah yeah yeah
okay and then then they're just going to
be on the post as well
i get it i get it
um the other thing too i definitely want
to talk about is the fact that you guys
do get to do a fourth one but taika this
is now
your second endeavor do you think of
this as
part of a new trilogy like how do you
think this film falls
that's an interesting question i haven't
thought about it as part of a new
trilogy
because every time i make a film i think
i'm never doing that again
and uh because they're just too hard
there's any film
and i've done it eight times now yeah
eight times i've said
i think i'm just going to pack it in
yeah i had a good run
and then
sure enough get lured back in with a
yankee dollar
all the money nerd back in by them
cookies and them oscars
i'm just saying i'm just saying i will
have to ask um both of you too because
i've gotten to interview a lot of folks
on taika's project both television film
and they always talk about the vibe he
creates on set that there's just a
different vibe
talk to us try and get folks prepared
for what it was like for you guys
filming on this one i hear there's lots
of music lots of music
yeah lots of music lots of that's a bit
of dancing occasionally a little bit
dancing some dancing yeah
snacks good snacks good snacks some
interesting direction
some of it's like
do you don't do that again chris yeah do
your jack sparrow impression and uh
which uh tesla once thought they played
this game and it was like doing
impressions and then his thing which she
had to guess jack sparrow
my direction is in a new zealand accent
and the fact that i don't know what i'm
talking about oh yeah i said i think it
was really great i think that uh just a
little next time
most of it is everything you do is uh
is stifled
by his
still laughing he started oh yeah or
yelling somebody else
ruined a lot of takes with laughing yeah
just yelling over around that because i
read some of our best stuff we'll never
see the light of day because it has you
laughing at the top of it
yeah i should just go direct from the
trailer you should do it from the truck
yeah yeah
okay become one of those
tiger will sit under the camera like
right here and just like whisper or yell
or scream suggestions yeah and um it's
fun it creates a spontaneity and an
insanity there yeah i think the classic
thing is what you get on youtube
do exactly like this okay
but however you want
and then no no
yeah
no
exactly
little bit perfect but not like that
what was your favorite under the camera
taika direction that he screamed out
from you either on this or from ragnarok
oh oh
there's really too
many to
remember and think about what's constant
the favorite is yeah it's pretty it's
it's pretty constant it never ends
really yeah right
what did the did the guardians did they
know that what they were getting into
when they came on set like did they have
any idea that that this was it like
what's the vibe now that you add in this
these sort of rag tag group of folks
that i'm sure just like what is going on
here
i know i have different name to james
james i think like or he directed me
brutally in a
suicide squad yeah and um he just knows
what he's doing that's the difference
he's got a plan and he knows every frame
that he's going to shoot and he
storyboards everything and he just knows
what he wants
well i'm just trying to like i'm like i
don't know what i want i'll see it
somewhere in there at some point the
first time i
met them all was on the infinity war set
and from that day there was just such a
different sort of vibe and energy that
each of the characters brought out in
each other and was the same with on this
film like it's a whole different dynamic
when you have
characters from another franchise who
are used to doing their own franchise
mashed into this world um
it was
like most of it
insane and hilarious and fun
what was the favorite moment from the
guardians or nebula or any of the new
folks well i didn't i i just came to set
to watch because i wasn't in any of the
guardian stuff and i don't remember
which of them said it to me but someone
asked me
is it always like this
i was like yes it is
yes it is
i think like
what you were saying taika i think it's
like maybe just we're used to a certain
like level of
chaos like existing in a certain level
of chaos because there's always like
the version that's on the page and then
the thing and then we throw that out and
do a bunch that's
that we know probably
maybe 95 of it will never
get to be in the film but you do it for
the five percent that can
live there just for the fun of like
we're here we got dressed up in these
stupid costumes and we may as well like
enjoy this moment rather than like
just be prescriptive and just do the one
line that's written there and the
residual effect of though that
conversation or that energy or that gag
that then trails into the actual
dialogue
has a different sort of nuance to it
yeah
i think that i want to just say real
quick on uniforms maybe we're not
supposed to say but
love your instagram picture what are the
of the new valkyrie clothes oh that no
see that's uh that's was it was my f i
sent a picture to my stepmom and she
posted it on instagram oh man oh really
i didn't know that yeah i wasn't me and
it's a big thing she feels terrible i'm
so sorry marvel i'm so sorry disney it's
not my fault i will never i'm never
gonna send selfies again
[Laughter]
i was behind mark ruffalo at the
premiere when he had his phone in his
pocket
and it was obviously live stream you're
you coming to the premiere and then he
was like great sat down and put this
pocket with a camera pointing out at the
screen and someone like ran in after 10
minutes
pulled the phone out of his pocket
because he had been streaming the movie
it was probably one of the greatest
i appreciate it though all right last
thing though on the new film and i know
you probably can't say but if we're
going to go and say taika verse we have
to talk about the multiverse because i
feel like marvel just added this like
wrench in all of you guys t now where
there can be different versions of every
event and you don't know which version
of loki between end game and some of the
other stuff they've done
oh god i know i just have to ask to me i
think this is an editorial multiverse
within this film
i was thinking
depending on which avenue you went down
with which improvised scene you have
this yeah there's a potential for 15
different versions of this movie that
would be so cool cause we should do that
one that where you can listen
adventure i really love the idea of like
just taking all of the footage and then
making it available and just saying to
someone else
make a move make your version of this
movie
yeah that's a cool idea i love this so
much now that we're four films deep
obviously everyone wants to talk about
the legacy of the thor films and the
legacy of the mcu i want you to um if
you could please just talk about what
you think is the legacy of the tiger
verse like these two films together what
do you want folks to take from them i'll
start with you tessa i don't know i
always thought when we made ragnarok the
whole concept of ragnarok is it
basically like destruction and inside of
destruction there's the opportunity for
creation like taika and i talk so much
about introducing valkyrie like what
does it look like if a female superhero
disrupts some of those like classic
tropes like what does that look like and
to me that feels like a unique
contribution which is to say like the
tropes are really cool it's why we all
tune in and we watch these movies
obsessively and also what can we do to
subvert them
that to me feels like the the legacy of
what our films do and hopefully continue
to get to do i love that mm-hmm what
about you sir i think what tiger does so
was so brilliantly in all of his films
and going right back to the first one i
saw which was boy
is there's a
wonderful amount of fun and adventure
and humor but
heart in the at the center of it and and
um
and and and love and and i do this is
what this film embodies and i think all
of his films have in in
in uh
many many layers just film definitely
like again we're not going to go on
about love too much
but
you know i keep thinking about those
moments in this film there are moments
in this film that
i think are very touching at the end you
know whether your film is for people to
have this
be swept away on this adventure and
escape and laugh and have fun but also
to feel something and i think you know
this film is quite emotional as well so
yeah i'm going to bring it to another
emotional side a bit too because um when
i was gearing up for this i let folks
know and like the love they have for
this particular franchise for you store
for you as valkyrie for your direction
is pretty intense like people were like
mad at me because i was going to be here
and i just have to ask you taika coming
into this i know the fans are so a big
part of how you make your films how has
it been to see their reaction it's quite
amazing when i first got
ragnarok
you know there were a few people who
were like who's this guy he's gonna ruin
everything and i was like that's the
point
that's not the point i'm coming in to
break it
and then make it in a new way and there
was a lot of love after that which was
great but it was also a you know as a
collaboration a joint effort like marvel
wanted to do something different
um which is why they brought me in chris
want to do something different i want to
do something different and
and just
i guess we all just thought what do we
want out of this film and let's try and
satisfy that want and that need
well i think you have folks that don't
know like i said tickets are on sale now
for thor love and thunder please don't
head over to fandango and you can pick
up your tickets now come get those
cookies
you